so thanks everybody for being patient
while I found the room today I'm going
to talk about this kind of us-china
friction especially in regard to
technology and kind of turned that
toward the technology management
imperatives
I'm Richard Asher I direct a Research
Center at Stanford called the u.s. Asia
Technology Management Center we were an
electrical engineering for 25 years but
two years ago we moved over to the
Stanford Global Studies program so I've
been on the news about this topic a
number of times but this is really one
of the first times that I've tried to
put together a real honest-to-goodness
lecture on the topic so we'll be very
interactive I will be looking forward to
your questions and your comments and
they may be reflected in the version of
the slides that we actually save so
first of all I want to talk about this
whole kind of feeling of deja vu I feel
like I've been here before
with technology conflict and then we'll
talk about understanding how the
us-china friction has come to be the way
that it is finally I'm going to talk
about a term you hear a lot in regard to
politics which is decoupling how to
disengage the economies of the US and
China and what's going to happen with
global supply chains and finally talk
about implications for technology
managers so yes
computer systems are very much at the
heart of this conflict we've had recent
issues with Huawei being named as an
entity with which US companies may not
do business and we have had also real
concern
typhoon Li last year wrote a big book on
AI superpowers about how the US and
China we're really going to go
head-to-head in regard to artificial
intelligence so really a lot of the
the conflicts now are right around areas
that this class is interested in but I
sure remember Japan back in the 1980s I
moved to Japan in 1986 I was in charge
of the Japan and Korea training programs
for American diplomats so I was an
employee of the US State Department I
had foreign service credentials
I was actually a section head of the
embassy although our language school our
area school was down in Yokohama and
when I got there it was all about memory
chips we were hearing that the Japanese
had been stealing IP right and left we
were hearing an awful lot about univer
Minh industry collusion how the Japanese
government was doing espionage on behalf
of Japanese companies and we're really
trying to take over the world from
America we had a lot of criticism about
research and development consortium that
were subsidized by the Japanese
government incidentally one of the
immediate outcomes of that was the
creation of the research center that I
used to run at Stanford the Center for
integrated systems because the Japanese
had this big consortium to study VLSI
large-scale computer chips the where it
is that John Young of HP and John Wynn
Ville of Stanford were in line at a gas
station and talked to each other about
the need for a some sort of way for
American industry to come together and
because of worries about any trust
problems the university was about the
only choice they had so they created C
is really to do Advanced Research and
semiconductors Japan was really
criticized at the time about having an
unfair low cost of capital and that the
Demark domestic market was closed and
it's true American memory chip companies
had less than six or seven percent of
the Japanese memory chip market back in
1983 so fast forward to about the year
you know 2015 and China is kind of the
new kid on the block and the nature of
the kind of conflict is no longer memory
chips it's really integrated network
technologies and things like artificial
intelligence that are critical enabling
technologies for all of the new kinds of
hardware and software China is being
accused of IP theft it's being accused
of government industry collusion
especially think about Huawei which yeah
it's kind of borderline is it really a
private company or not uh we have a
number of policies in China that people
are worried about Chinese companies are
accused of an unfair low cost of capital
and the domestic market in China sure
looks closed if you're in China unless
you're on some sort of a VPN you're not
going to be able to use Google you're
not going to be able to see Facebook
you're not going to be able to use
Twitter the list goes on so there were
some differences Japan never had the
potential to be a major rival of the
United States like China does first of
all Japan was completely dependent on
America for security and also Japan had
half the population in the US with China
let's face it if income levels per
person in China reach that of the United
States which is you know you can't want
people to be able to improve their lives
if they come up to the level of
individual income that's in the US the
Chinese economy will be four times as
big as the US because there are four
times as many people there the object of
concern between the US and China is
arguably even more pervasive and
ubiquitous
you know computer chips were back in the
early 1980s the world is in cloud
computing now 96% of companies are using
cloud-based solutions for one thing or
another also more and more applications
are real time and of analytics is an
absolutely essential part of dealing
with the huge amounts of data that are
being created every day smartphones are
everywhere and so actually I think that
the technology conflict between the US
and China in regard to things like 5g
networks in regard to artificial
intelligence are really incredibly
pervasive and China is not necessarily
an American ally this means that there
is a national security aspect to
American concerns about advanced
technology even more than applied to the
us-japan conflict a few years ago now
the thing about government industry
collusion you have to look at in terms
of how technologies develop people
outside the US really good worried about
the role of the US Defense Department
that DARPA you know the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency is some sort of
something that's feeding everything to
the American military when really this
reflects one of those strange things
about how American R&D can be funded
over the history since World War two
Americans don't like to see the
government supporting big companies even
if they do if you can put that under the
label of Defense you can get money and I
know a lot of people who told me that
you know basically the difference
between the DARPA presentation of the
Department of Commerce presentation is
that you'll have a picture of the tank
or a fighter plane
somewhere on the DARPA presentation
there's not a whole lot of other
difference but yeah the internet started
out as a defense project and with China
you do have this kind of comprehensive
view of national development where the
government is taking the lead to develop
infrastructure of various sorts and that
certainly led to a lot of the early
deployment of artificial intelligence in
China there will be a handoff to
industry for innovation R&D can be
funded by a government but eventually as
the government starts to support things
that move into industry for commercial
application the government starts to
want to buy off-the-shelf it's cheaper
consumers benefit from access but it was
not a trivial point when ARPANET started
being the internet back in the late
1980s so industry efficiency takes over
and it's you know the globalization that
we have seen since about 1985 this is an
entire generation that has been built on
globalization including Silicon Valley
we look for the best providers meaning
the most cost-efficient providers as
well as quality providers and we look
for international markets to support the
next generation of R&D one reason that
Huawei
did as well as they did with 5g was
Chinese government investment in
infrastructure but the other reason why
didn't the American telecom companies
get into this is because they assumed
they'd be able to buy off-the-shelf they
were looking for better value-added
layers of the technology stack and
American companies are much further
ahead or have been until recently in
regard to the data processing side but
the basic radio access all that kind of
stuff
that's commodity work so sure enough the
American telcos didn't invest in 5g they
were going to buy it so this kind of
thing has happened and kind of fast
forwarding to where the point of this
whole talk is gonna go today American
companies innovate their way out of
trouble so one of the companies that was
suffering the most during the memory
chip wars between the u.s. and Japan was
Intel Intel was a memory chip company
until about 1985 or 86 when Intel
decided to switch over to this emerging
architecture around a CPU around a
microprocessor up until that time
computers had been mainframes and it was
really the advent of a standard
microprocessor that enabled the whole
development of PCs that enable the whole
development of client-server
architecture and really has led to the
whole kind of data center based cloud
architecture that we have now so I think
that what has happened is that America
innovated its way out look at the
history of Silicon Valley every seven or
eight years we have another major kind
of technology revolution that leads to a
new industry and we will have one or two
world leading companies coming out of
Silicon Valley that's the way Silicon
Valley stays ahead now unfortunately
other parts of the country especially
where manufacturing is centered aren't
leading these new revolutions and
they've been kind of left behind by
innovation and this is the origin of a
lot of the political kind of conflicts
that have led to the desire by America
to be couple yeah go ahead
I remember the head of AT&T Labs telling
me about 1993 in the internet well when
you see a lot of the security stuff that
we have now relate to that kind of
history it was an open method of sharing
information and data among researchers
OneNote is nothing yeah okay I think
that's true but I think that your point
is a
example of how a government-funded
research project which basically
established an infrastructure on
government money was then available for
the commercial sector to use and take
advantage of and really was a no latency
problem or what was there was a no
latency problem okay well I remember in
the mid-1990s there were two kind of
major packet switching technologies that
were in competition the Japanese were
promoting OCI and tcp/ip that was coming
along it was starting to be popular but
I think the system here in the US
gradually saw that standardization and
as that standardized that really allowed
the internet to fundamentally change the
nature of network computing I remember
spreading Ethernet cable
between computers in the State
Department back when I worked for the
State Department and basically the
length had to be exactly the same you
know you had to have exactly you know
the same number of millimetres length
cable between the computers or the
sequencing wouldn't work yeah right so
anyway as the internet really spread
basically a local area network became
nothing more than something bounded by a
firewall right and now you've got
Internet Protocol inside just about
everything even your toaster in your
refrigerator so what you see is you do
see the spread of standards and you know
kind of the thing with of what's
happening with industry evolution and
the us-china friction there are some new
areas like key networks and also I would
have to say that anything you had put on
that technology stack like a
self-driving car our areas in which
China is developing its own solutions
and a lot of government infrastructure
investment has happened in China that
bothers American industry a lot but
really if you look at the history since
the memory chip worsley with Japan the
u.s. innovated its way to do just fine
at least Silicon Valley did just fine
and the Japanese and Korean companies
kind of get stuck in middle levels of
kind of this evolution they will get
government support for research and
build out a lot of stuff but the kind of
commercial winning applications
well we can get we can get into that
though I think these days that is an
area of computing that has gone ahead so
far you know even I can is reppin is
recognizing internet addresses that can
be put together in 8-bit code instead of
English type Roman letter code let me go
through the slides okay we'll come back
so anyway one of the things that doesn't
tend to happen that much in other
economies that happens here is the use
of disruptive innovation the startup
companies here really have brought in a
lot but they've done that because we're
kind of freewheeling and we will let
them take revenues away from existing
companies you know Google and these
companies really got to be as big as
they are by disrupting the newspaper
industry and then the TV industry so
that's the kind of thing where if there
is real closed government industry
cooperation the government tends to be
able to protect the industries more you
get a protected industry that is not as
agile and not as competitive so right
now up until this point China has been
all about building out infrastructure
developing the economy it is finally
moving into the stage of really being an
innovation driven economy I got some
slides on that but first of all look at
these things you know if you're
comparing what has happened right with
the memory chips the memory chip market
really left Japan and went to South
Korea the flat panel display market left
Japan and went to South Korea we were
really worried about
and he's working flat panel displays
when I first started here at Stanford
and now the majority of manufacturing is
going on in Taiwan cellphones may go all
the way to China telecom networks may go
all the way to China but the u.s. does
okay by looking at value-added
businesses that take advantage of these
new technologies we innovate our way out
of trouble so let's look a little bit
more at how we got to where the US and
China are first of all how many people
here know that China's economy is
already bigger than the United States
okay yeah in purchasing power and it's
getting close in nominal terms to in
fact the way that this developed looks
like this and this is why China has been
so interesting people-to-people for a
long time the the china chart is going
way up to the top and America had the
transition point was somewhere around
2015 India is going up but not nearly as
much as China now as an economy develops
the World Economic Forum recognizes
three main stages of economic
development and the first stage what we
would typically call an early stage
developing economy they call factor
driven and this is where you see huge
numbers of people moving to cities so in
the United States the late 1800s before
the war in Japan after World War two in
Korea in the early 1980s
you have industrialization going on and
it really looks like a gold rush china
has looked an awful lot like a gold rush
where the most important thing was to
get there first establish your claim and
start your business the government was
essentially doing basic commercial code
laws basic IP laws this
second stage is when the first
generation of companies become
successful suddenly the economy is
growing at such a pace that you have a
labor shortage and this is the stage at
which government's often try to pick
winners the Japanese picked some of
their chaotzu companies after world war
ii and really did help them out the kind
of key competitive advantage that this
is how to develop new markets and scale
up it doesn't matter whether they're
domestic or international if you've got
a big local market you can scale up
domestically first Japan auto industries
really only started to scale up
internationally when they needed the
revenue to support domestic competition
and I think that you compare that to
Korea which has half the number of
people or a third of the number of
people as in Japan and you see earlier
internationalization they have to go to
international markets earlier and then
you see someplace like Israel and you
better be thinking international from
the first day you start your company
this is where high quality becomes kind
of a key feature of the best companies
in the economy you also see the kind of
operational efficiency like just-in-time
purchasing and all that kind of stuff
and it's only after you have a domestic
base of industries that governments get
serious about enforcing IP why should we
enforce intellectual property if all the
intellectual property is owned by
somebody foreign you know the people
that got me into office or that I need
to support me in office are domestic so
once I have a group of domestic people
who need IP enforcement it will happen
then
really along about 35,000 a year in
revenue per person is when you get the
next generation after that and I think
part of its generational in a efficiency
driven economy you have people who work
in line jobs in factories earning 60 or
70 dollars an hour it's great you know
but
fortunately that era doesn't last and
most of these people don't want their
kids working online jobs and factories
education spreads through the economy
and as higher education spreads through
the economy nobody really wants the old
jobs that were sort of the key to the
previous generation so this is where
creative new ideas really become the key
competitive strengths the brilliance of
Steve Jobs knowing what people would
have to have before they had ever seen
it this means that for a company you
have to be able to allow enough risk to
be trying out these fresh new ideas it's
at this point that you really see the
government's trying to support
entrepreneurship and put in fiscal money
to help bridge the valley of death right
where you've got development costs and
you know in the United States it was the
early 1980s when the SBIR grant system
started to really help high tech
companies get from the research stage
into the commercialization stage where
they could talk to private sector
investors so these this is really kind
of important backdrop to remember what's
going on in China especially because now
if you look at China China is as a
nation still at the end of the
efficiency driven stage partly because
the interior is still so undeveloped but
in the East Coast cities it's acting
more and more like an innovation driven
economy so right now you're seeing the
first Chinese companies that are really
trying to go global who really went
global in terms of sales before Alibaba
and 10 cent solar PV they were actually
selling more in China I my Senses device
I think that was a little after Alibaba
came along but they really ran the
people
out of the business here what you had
was you had a very protected market in
China so that all the people here tried
to go into China and sell there and they
couldn't compete but yeah that's a it's
a good point finally you're seeing
globalization and so they're aiming at
global markets another thing going on in
China this year is a huge rise in VC
we'll talk a little bit about there's
also worry in China that as a structure
the economy is not ready to support
higher levels of income there's
something called the middle income trap
that hits around this you know sixteen
to seventeen thousand dollars a year
where it's very difficult for companies
to really change their way of thinking
to see their competitiveness as being
driven by fresh new ideas instead of by
you know quality and scale up and that
kind of thing in Japan you do have an
innovation driven economy same thing in
South Korea but the big firms haven't
really gotten comfortable with that yet
the biggest thing is they haven't
learned how to deal with startup
companies well I mean that's what we've
got with this disruptive innovation
thing it's not just a lot of startup
companies it's the big companies buying
from the startup companies and
partnering with them and acquiring them
so that the big companies continue to
grow fast India is an interesting space
the place it's really islands of highly
advanced technologies in the middle of a
very much an early stage to developing
economy so you have the international
business sector in India and then you
have the domestic sector in India
I think 97 percent of Infosys as
revenues come from foreign countries so
it's you know Indians kind of an
interesting space now China has made a
lot of news in the last five years but
really
you know us business has been having a
hard time in China for a long time not
this is not new the domestic market in
China is huge
you see rapid economic growth and so
everybody's really interested in it
China also had a lot of strength because
of the labor cost difference between
there in the u.s. not only because
workers were cheap but they worked hard
they had a great work ethic and the
level of literacy the level of education
is very high so it's not only that you
had a cheap workforce that you had a
really good workforce oh but along about
five or six years ago the actually
closer to ten now the economy in China
really suddenly reached a drastic
slowdown part of this was the timing was
engineered by the government but it had
to as an economy moves up the scale to
being you know from efficiency driven to
innovation driven the infrastructure
development contributes less to the
economy than does consumer spending and
so now China is a more consumer driven
economy but the whole level of growth is
somewhere around six percent now as a
general rule this is not about China if
the economy slows down you protect your
people first so you get a protectionist
economy when the economy slows that's
just really natural oh and I have to say
that in China as in the u.s. we have a
real kind of you know America first idea
and in China there's a real you know
China first attitude especially among
young people young people are very you
know patriotic in China so the other
thing that's happening though is the
disappearance the labor cost differences
China is suddenly a lot less attractive
as a manufacturing location for American
businesses partly because of the
difficulties of dealing with the
government and
the system and so forth but also because
of yet nons a lot cheaper and you can
move things to other places and do just
as well as you've been doing in China
um but China has had has grown up in the
last thirty five years as a key point in
the global supply chain China is the
place where the final product tends to
be put together like my iPhone was
probably put together in Shenzhen but
the stuff inside the iPhone comes from
eight or nine different countries and
depending on how many levels you go down
the chips in the iPhone may come from
Japan and Korea but those chips
themselves involve designs that were
made in one country and a chip that was
tabbed down in TSMC and Taiwan and then
mounted somewhere in Malaysia and so you
you have these global supply chain but
China was the point for final assembly
and then from China it would go to
typically advanced markets this is still
kind of the situation and the decoupling
that the American government is trying
to do is to try to get American
companies to pull their manufacturing
meaning their final assembly back to the
US we'll come back to that yeah it's
interesting
China is a really tough place to do
business
speaking of solar cells I knew the
person that represented the German Q
cell company in China a German guy who
spoke fluent Mandarin lived there for
ten years achieved nothing finally he
left and quit and you know the company
later went bankrupt so China is a really
tough place to do business always has
been there were regulations in China and
also cultural things in China that
strongly favored or required you to have
a local partner so
I lost some money in this way I invested
in a company that was based outside of
China and so they created a local
partner in China and started to develop
the China market and allowed the company
that I invested in to go bankrupt while
the China company did just fine cause
the only relationship between the China
company and the parent was a technology
license anyway so you know that's been
around that was 20 years ago that was a
long time yes there has been a lot of
intellectual property theft no one will
argue that China has not been violating
the terms of the World Trade
Organization and that's just one of
those things for a long time American
business because they had this image of
being able to do work in China well it
kind of put pressure on the American
government not to enforce a situation
against China too much and you know what
they would do is they come up with other
strategies no one would send their most
advanced technology to China right you
said last generation technology to China
or if you've got a complicated system
you send everything except the real
critical components to China the the
commodity stuff and get from there but
you know the thing that really makes
your system work you do somewhere else
one of my favorite stories is how
Microsoft dealt with the piracy
something like 96% of the copies of
Windows 95 this is old story but 96% of
the of the copies of Windows 95 in China
were pirate so what did Microsoft do
Microsoft implemented a service based
business model where when somebody would
have a problem with their Windows system
they would call up Microsoft support and
Microsoft support would say oh I'm sorry
you don't have a registered version
we'll be happy to send you one for them
that's contract so you know they found
ways around it the companies that were
suffering from trademark infringement
and there are different laws in China
about what you can trademark and how you
have to justify the trademark or patent
even it was kind of pointless to take it
to Chinese Court
so instead like the movie makers in the
US would have a real close relationship
with the customs officials in China and
tell them that some you know contraband
stuff is coming in it or a warehouse go
raided and so they would use this
administrative action instead of
litigation in China so American
companies have known how to do this if
you're a company of any size you bring
in your people and you find out what to
do but more recently China is really
moving into the realm of being a direct
competitor in advanced technology to
what we're doing I think this goes back
20 years I think it really starts with a
major move in the Chinese university
system back in 1998 to consolidate and
create world-class universities China
universities have been built on the old
Soviet Union model where they were
narrowly focused on particular areas so
for instance jaejoong university down in
hangzhou is the merger the result of a
merger of five different universities in
that city and they threw a lot of money
at them then there have been various
policies that people really worried
about indigenous innovation meaning the
government was going to support
innovation in China as opposed to buying
off-the-shelf from somewhere else they
had the made in China policy that
they've kind of toned down a lot but it
was basically something where they were
going to promote national makers and the
whole thing about artificial
intelligence being a major national
strategic priority in
has also made a lot of people nervous
but sure enough as China has developed
their IP enforcement is much better than
it used to be that is something that a
lot of people are not aware of but
foreign companies in China actually have
a higher percentage of court case wins
than domestic companies and you know not
only that but China is concerned about
this being a competitive advantage so
they've tried to make sure that the the
time it takes to educate a lawsuit is
short it's one of the shortest in the
world so the other thing that's happened
is a drastic increase because they got a
domestic industry now they've got
domestic players who are going to be
really unhappy if somebody next door
steals their IP yep it's a great
question and it is really because now
it's - everybody's advantage to have
stability in terms of knowing what you
own when you are on IP now that doesn't
mean it's disappeared but it hasn't
disappeared here either I mean we have
IP enforcement of problems here
sometimes so the second thing the the
third thing there is drastic increase in
money being thrown at new innovative
ideas meaning the venture capital
industry here's a chart of venture
capital in the US and in China from 2010
the first half of 2018 the amount has
come to be about the same amount as in
the United States now there is a second
slide that I didn't put into this
presentation the number of deals is
still not as much as
in the US so you have more big deals big
venture capital investments in China and
part of that is probably because the
public markets in China are still not
exactly you know great yeah some of it
is laundered government money some on it
but it's you know yeah I did have action
well it depends because a lot of things
times watchful habits will have money
from a bank going into a venture capital
fund but where did the bank of the money
right especially since the you know at
least half the banks are state-owned so
I think that you do see government
interest there you see an alignment of
the venture capital industry with
government priorities but that's kind of
logical if I was a venture capital
investor I'd go with what I think's
gonna make Ritu so anyway that's a big
deal and the other thing that I'd like
to point out is the government has been
a major customer for a lot of the
advanced technology solutions since time
this special recognition company that's
based in Hong Kong but does most of
their business in China and I dare say
probably 70% of their income has come
from government projects they're the
people that sell the cameras for the
cities to watch the people crossing the
street so you know the government as a
customer is a big thing anyway the kind
of final section of the talk is really
about this decoupling and what happens
when the supply chains unravel first of
all the US government is actively trying
to disengage the American economy from
the Chinese economy the tariffs which
are a way of supposedly leveling the
playing field if you think the products
in another country are unfairly cheap
have turned into something where
basically the government is trying to
make components more expensive and you
know our president sent a note to Tim
Cook at Apple saying we really think you
ought to move your manufacturing back to
the US now if we do it the Chinese are
going to do it so this means it happens
in both ways our stuff going into China
become more expensive so yes if business
does that things fall back there's an
increase scope of enforcement of export
controls now export controls apply
mostly to technologies without regard to
which foreign country you're talking
about there are technologies that may
have military applications as well as
commercial applications first of all
what can't have a military application
now right I mean that's a real issue
there are more than 650 pages of
technologies in very small print that
are subject to the Export Control reform
Act and you know half a dozen different
US government departments are enforcing
these Department of State enforces some
Department of Defense enforces some
Department of Commerce enforces some
there's an increased scrutiny of foreign
investments in American firms the turn
you'll hear most of the time is Sidious
the Committee on foreign investment in
the US that's the group inside the
government it's an interagency group
that's supposed to manage this process
of looking to see if accepting a foreign
investor into a US startup is
to lead American technology to go
outside the US in violation of the
export control so Cepheus is a big deal
the actual regulations themselves are
just this past year fi our RMA firma but
yeah this is this is noticeable and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
in a minute
another thing that is definitely aimed
at decoupling is the much more severe
environment for getting a visa to come
to the United States and I haven't
really paid attention to reciprocity by
China yet but certainly in the US this
is a big deal I had about thirty percent
of my visitors from China last year were
denied a visa for short term visits to
do things like open seminars and I think
that a lot of it is not so much the
regulation as it is an attitude that's
had to develop in the State Department
to preserve their budget in the current
administration State Department
officials are I think evaluated on how
many pieces they turn down
that's a suspicion I don't have any you
know don't have any kind of evidence on
that and then the last thing to mention
are these entity lists of specific
companies that the u.s. prohibits from
doing business with American firms so
you ship it out now these appear to be
based in a 1980 style view of how to
rebalance the trade situation between
the US and China yes the US and China
the US has a huge trade trade deficit to
China but you know these kinds of
decoupling issues are not really going
to help the US firms are not going to
take all those jobs back
the US and unlike Japan China has a big
enough domestic market that it figures
they can do without the US especially if
it the third country markets also I
think we're going to start to see the
impact on things like inflation and
prices consumer prices here in the US
before too long and so if this is what
it takes to get the trade back to
balance with less of a trade deficit the
you know the medicines going to be very
you know unpleasant to take here I think
that you're seeing shift of the supply
chains from China to other countries
you're seeing really the development of
a completely different system in China
I remember 12 or 13 years ago China
announced that it was going to do its
own technology standards for a number of
critical computer related technologies
including Wi-Fi including computer
operating systems you can't do this
unless you have a domestic market that
is potentially huge so because they had
a big domestic market they'll they'll go
a different route Huawei's already
announced a new operating system for its
phones since it cannot use Google
Android although maybe that's been
delayed forget what the situation is
this week but in any case while we
developed a new operating system based
on Russian model so you know we're not
necessarily going to be able to hold
them to American things and I think that
as the US companies stay out of China
then China companies may stay out in the
US what's wrong with that picture
how many Japanese cars do we sell here
you know how many what percentage of my
iPhone comes from Japan American
consumers have been a
greatly by having more people competing
in world markets so the benefits of
globalization have not been understood
by the American public that's one of the
real problems now in that situation what
you do if you're a technology manager
first of all be prepared to pay a lot
more to your lawyer I here
it costs about three hundred thousand
dollars to do due diligence that you're
in compliance with Sidious and probably
the export control would you know
throwing export controls for another
hundred or something so the law firms
here there have been at least ten major
presentations about export controls and
Cepheus by law firms in this area in the
last two months
yeah if their stock is available the
other problem with these new regulations
though is the time that it takes it
takes about six months to do the due
diligence on a foreign investor which
means that I'm hearing things like a
venture capitalist came to me the other
day and said we want to hire a new
associate make sure they're an American
citizen
okay so you know that kind of time
factor is going to be a major
disadvantage for startups here but the
real competition is moving to Southeast
Asia
right uber lost out to DD although they
were both trying to get into the
Southeast Asian markets now when Chinese
companies move into a foreign market
they tend to buy a local partner or buy
into a local partner and increase their
presence that way Americans tend to
think that the whole world acts like
America and so they just started their
company overseas office there
so uber found out that they couldn't be
successful and they sold out their
Southeast Asia business to a
singapore-based competitor grab which
incidentally has almost a billion
dollars of money from the Chinese
company didi tushy so yeah anyway this
is this third country markets will it be
America versus the rest of the world or
will it be China first as the rest of
the world and the US has been putting
serious pressure on other countries not
to adopt huawei's 5g system but they've
only had limited success and I think
Brazil was the most recent one to say
will buy from whoever we want to buy so
you know this this kind of global
competition is definitely going to be
two spheres of influence rubbing into
each other but the good side of that is
if Chinese companies do go global more
they may have to open up the China
market more the main reason that you
would want to open a protected market to
foreign competition is if your own
companies need to be able to compete in
foreign countries makes sense so I think
that that's you know possibly a might
actually there's a possibility that it
won't be a terrible outcome but the last
thing the real imperative for a
technology manager here is innovate if
you see something that looks like the
you know it's going to be owned by
somebody else come up with a new
business model come up with a new
technology and that's that's our
tradition here in Silicon Valley the
kind of clothes on this is that I think
the US and China will probably reach
some sort of trade agreement I think
that there is too much pressure on the
countries to completely go apart
and I think that if this does involve
greater global attention on the part of
the China government then maybe we'll be
good for China companies and maybe
you'll be good for everybody but it is
still a risky situation and the other
thing is China needs to watch out about
what economic development model it looks
at they're in serious danger of
following the path of the Japanese and
Koreans meaning big companies that have
too much control over capital and too
much control over market access and so
they become kind of less than innovative
yeah so I think that the new innovation
demands for startup companies in China
are going to be much more high-tech than
they used to be it really you know the
day that Groupon was announced I think
there were 650 competitors in China
immediately same business same kind of
model now a Chinese entrepreneur is
going to have to develop something more
interesting to have a chance to be
successful that's just the way you know
the innovation based economic
development works I think that if the
Chinese big companies can develop a good
ecosystem for open innovation
relationships with startup companies
they'll do really well that is the area
where I think Japan and Korea has not
done so well and it's hard to tell
they're certainly doing investments the
big Chinese companies are doing a lot of
investing whether they are really using
the startup companies as strategic input
to their major to corporate strategy or
not like Google does it's hard to tell
yet so I do think that there's a danger
that China will wind up recreating the
Japanese case
and that's really kind of what I had
prepared for today thanks for listening
so much I'd love to hear your comments
[Applause]
just like the people in Iraq right well
I think that first of all it is a huge
question mark where this is going in
China if China is developing an
innovation driven economy that's
basically a market driven economy a
market driven economy by definition is
not controlled by the state and so how
long they can keep this coexistence
without real pressure coming up is a
good question I'm afraid that the
situation in Hong Kong may be an
indicator if they crack down and then
they really go harsh under control again
that may have a real negative effect on
innovation in China and so I think it's
a big question whether they're really
moving apart that way or not if I have a
tenement square in Hong Kong people
become afraid people well yeah people
want to do what is the officially
approved solution to the problem and you
know having out-of-the-box thinking is
really essential in another kind of
thing
Yeah right right just there how long can
that last really yeah yeah no I think
that's a you've got a really good
question and part of the reason that's
hard to deal with China is you can't see
where it's headed I think that there's
probably some latent feelings against
the government that not disappeared
before Xi Jinping people would criticize
the government pretty openly I was at a
big dinner with hosted by a successful
kind of marketing guru while University
of the parties horrible and you know he
was really seriously angry I I was at
another reception this year in Shanghai
and I kind of talked a little bit about
us-china situation and this person came
up to me at the end and said Richard I
understand China just remember we have
the biggest mafia in the world the party
[Laughter]
okay now whether crush them is the right
idea or not I think that severe
enforcement of rule based kind of
international standards would be a good
thing I think before Trump the Obama
administration was wait a week okay in
foreign policy and especially Roseman in
regard to China and I think that what
we've done though is we're not using the
right tools so the WTO the World Trade
Organization is pretty weak and really
needs a lot of health it kind of reminds
me of the League of Nations before World
War two so I hope we don't have to have
a war to change this but if they could
give the WTO some teeth you know that
could be - everybody's advantage
yes that's right and that'll go on as
long as this current administration is
around and unless people understand why
an international rule space system is
better for everybody
we're always going to have populist
people who look for somebody to blame
for all of our problems and say we
should crush them I mean you know that's
it's a great solution the only problem
is just not right not the right one okay
I think you have a really good point and
I don't like a lot of the trappings of
current capitalism okay when it's all
about making every penny that you can
make at the expense of social good or at
the expense of the environment or
whatever it that's not the right thing I
agree that the internet was good because
it was an open standard but from my
memory things were really different
after that
came along and advertising came into the
internet very soon after that and so I I
kind of think that it's interesting
what's happening with the big IT
companies now everybody wants to have
their own platform IOT platform is like
you know got another one and to take
something that you develop in-house I
got um Watson where everything is
in-house and then turn it into a
platform for third-party developers and
third-party people to build applications
on you're opening it out exactly as you
say so they're making that same choice
that openness and open source may be a
better way to go but they do that with
the understanding that they can make
money somehow now I don't necessarily
think that the current capitalist system
is perfect by any means and I don't
necessarily like a lot of what we've
come into now and it wouldn't surprise
me if we see the split up of the big IT
firms you know the Google Facebook
Amazon Group just because we saw the oil
companies split up in the 1920s it's
going to be the same kind of thing and
the oil companies now are not doing too
badly so you know I think the there is a
very important government for role in
ensuring safety for people and ensuring
you know enough kind of fairness that
people can bring a new business idea to
market I think that if you ask me what
really bothers me about China right now
it's what's going on with the NBA the
NBA right we're now China's not going to
broadcast nearly as many of the NBA
games because of something that one of
the NBA coaches said a few weeks ago and
that kind of paranoid
fear of what is said in the press is
something that we won't be happy and the
company is afraid secrets well and Apple
was so horrible enough that it refused
to open up an iPhone from somebody you
know that committed some horrible crime
right in this country in this country
and that is one of these basic kind of
things that we've grown up with this
culture that values the privacy side and
there's always a trade-off between
privacy and security if you tell the
government everything about what you're
doing yeah they'll take care of you this
huawei system my understanding it was
developed at an institution in Moscow
some you know Technology Research
Institute probably is
so they did work yeah and you've got a
big enough economy to support that kind
of thing well I think it reveals what
the Hoover Institution here called sharp
power that China really doesn't like any
criticism of what China is doing and
will take all kinds of measures to
ensure that they're not criticized and I
was interviewed by channel 7 about the
Hong Kong situation about a month ago
and right before the camera started
rolling
chrysten see the the moderate you know
the news woman asked me are you neutral
are you assuming that if I'm getting
money from Chinese sources that probably
I'm not going to tell the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
yeah what oh okay well that's just fine
you didn't miss much yeah you have come
to write you had a difficult oh okay
okay yeah no I think that this sharp
power is one of the real sticking points
that is really hard to reconcile
coexistence about you know I grew up in
the Cold War I remember what this was
like and we had all these things about
peaceful coexistence and appreciate you
know paying is shoe in the basket the UN
saying we will bury you
yeah complete control over the media
scares me because people make their
decisions based on what they know and if
you don't have access to multiple
sources of information that's not a good
thing
I mean but I'm extreme ever since I was
a little I used to DX a shortwave radio
so you know I that's kind of what really
bothers me about the NB a situation was
that just a negotiation issue or because
my understanding is it does have to be
51% oh and there may be some areas you
know we have a few business areas in
technology areas where we have
limitations on foreign ownership of
firms here in the US and so it could be
something like that but I also think
that it's kind of what you can do and if
you're able to have an enforceable
contract where you're really getting the
revenue that you want and you're not
transferring technology that will be
that will tell you miss in the next
generation of technology then ownership
is not nearly as important as the cash
go ahead
you have a variation I did have a chart
somewhere about 5g adoption and what
companies were saying you know we're
going to go we're not going to buy the
Chinese stuff or we will buy from
whoever we want to census that for the
short term
the US has allies that are aligned with
it the Japanese are definitely with the
the US yeah but that kind of thing could
be changed relatively quickly right
that's a decision that a government
could make and change I think that
getting serious about look you know what
these guys are doing partly because the
person I was talking to had been in the
was a ambassador in government negotiate
car issues with China I the feeling that
he kind of wanted the American
negotiation and then they'll come in and
through the market just like all of our
trade negotiations about poles and
cherries and stuff III think that our
allies have been supportive up to a
point but almost everybody agrees that
the tariffs are not 1980s trade balances
misses the structural issues of a global
supply chain that up to the 1980s and so
you know the old solutions that we seem
to be aiming for now are not going to
work in the year 2020 there's a lot of
people who in those terms when I'm in
foreign countries I'm hearing that a lot
you and I are old enough to remember
that la under 30 you don't know what the
heck we're talking about so I think that
cause I could get people in China
talking about the future of China pretty
easy up until about 2013 or 2014 and now
just there's no upside compensation and
I think that the Chinese are not doing
the same kind of investment that the
Japanese are but caused the Japanese and
this kind of goes back to your point the
Japanese big K debts and companies that
really emerged in this deficiency driven
economy era were private sector
companies and there was enough of them
that they basically control market and
in China there's only a handful of the
really giant IT companies now and you
know once you get maybe why way and hire
and I think that a different dynamic so
the Chinese are really doing more kind
of purchasing driven development where
[Music]
many you know AI based stations in this
kind of network and that is a different
pattern than the Japanese approach I
don't think there are the coin industry
labs in China that there were in Japan
you know a big national project like the
fifth-generation project would have its
central lab where all the people came
from competing companies but they were
working together yeah it was a failure
[Laughter]
so this is why human resource
development is always a goal of
government programs whether they admit
it or not yeah it doesn't help the bio
the show yeah true I think it's easier
to do it the first time around then once
you've got an established system going
because it really does look like
government support for particular
companies and that's never been popular
in the US yeah but you almost never saw
a brand name for who actually made the
components of the rockets and so forth
they were there that were commercial
providers yeah well in terms of locked
up 5g is a really complicated set of
standards and it's at least three major
waves of standards the first ones that's
already starting deployed in places like
and in China really uses frequencies
that are not too different from the
frequencies that are currently in use
the second and third generations will be
using millimeter wave stuff and that
search phase still that's still several
years away what I've heard is that
Huawei's technologies are probably
several years ahead of anything anybody
else has more advanced they work well I
do think that the radio access for ultra
high speed through you know high-speed
communications and also multi multiple
stream communications where 5g handles
data in a different way than 4G does and
so they've they've solved a lot of those
problems how are you gonna divide up the
load between edge processing and cloud
processing the data center processing
anything it has to be dynamic but you
look to the air apparently think the
Chinese are that far ahead
those are areas that are still just
emerging clouds are application driven
areas and I would look at the
intelligent robot people as well as the
sought the self-driving car people as
likely to have an impact on that
probably the intelligence robot
intelligent robots more because it'd be
easier to put 5g inside a factory than
it will be inside a whole neighborhood
so yeah but I you know we were asleep I
don't really think that stole the IP
from that many people to develop 5g I
think they had good government work that
paid for the R&D and the government they
made a pitch to the government said this
is important the government said go for
it
they develop technology